These aren't nests.
They're waste dumps for
a truly monster tunneling
project, a termite
megacity the size of
Great Britain.
It dwarfs any city that
humans have ever built.
It's mind boggling.
Analysis suggests that
every year the insects
here excavate over 50
million tons of soil.
The amount that's been
moved around to build
these tremendous mounds
is the equivalent of 4000
great Pyramids of Giza.
This is a huge structure
built by tiny insects.
Soil analysis confirms
some of these insect
mounds are 4000 years
old, built more than 2000
years before the rise of
the Roman Empire.
And the excavation that
produced them is the most
extensive bioengineering
effort by a single insect
species anywhere on the
planet.
This is actually a mega
city.